each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so the project we call it log based
architectures this is this is a project
that's being done jointly between
researchers at Intel and and faculty and
students at Carnegie Mellon and actually
one person I wanted to point out in
particular is Asha min chen who was a
Microsoft fellow and he was an intern
here at Microsoft working with David
will make everything Shannon touches
turns to gold so this he's not allowed
to help this project and unlike a lot of
talks you probably hear so I suggested a
couple of talks to trishul n minus one
of them were very mature talks and then
one of them was very not mature and this
is the unmatured one but but that's okay
because I'm interested in talking about
it because this is something where we
would like to get feedback and input and
things from other people and I think
that people here at Microsoft would
would give us really great feedback on
what we're trying to do so we call it
log based architectures and it's not
this kind of a log based architecture
it's something else the the motivation
for this is that you know programmers
and people use software care both about
correctness or having the program
correct behave properly and performance
but until something's really behaving
properly it doesn't matter if it's fast
so if it's fast and broken that's not
very satisfying so our focus here Lee
here is more on getting things to behave
properly and what in particularly we can
are we concerned about first of all bugs
so it's hard to avoid having bugs and
software especially if you're writing
large pieces of software and I've been
some studies that have suggested that
this problem isn't getting better it may
be getting worse as systems become
larger and larger and maybe more complex
it gets harder to avoid bugs and the
other problem with bugs is that they
don't just sit there and wait to be
exercised as they would in nature people
like design security attacks that
specifically exploit these bugs and take
advantage of them and almost everything
is
the network these days so that's a real
concern and finally there's concern that
in the future the hardware might become
a little bit less reliable we may have
to worry more about transient hardware
fault so so that's these are some
reasons why we worry about things
misbehaving now as you've probably heard
Intel AMD and the processor companies
are now shifting over toward multi-core
chip multiprocessing the idea is today
they're shipping to processors on a chip
and soon it'll be four eight 16 128 and
so on and how will this change the
picture well first there's some bad news
which is if you thought it was hard to
get a single threaded program behaving
correctly it's going to be even more
challenging to get a multi-threaded or
parallel program behaving correctly and
even if you get it behaving correctly a
big part of the motivation at least for
writing a parallel program is for it to
run faster and there are a lot of
performance gotchas that can occur and
take away all of your speed up if you're
not careful and the tools that we like
to use in sequential programs are not
necessarily as powerful as we like them
to be four or useful as we'd like them
to be four parallel programs but there
is some good news here which is that the
fact that we're going to have these
extra cores gives us this opportunity to
do more in the background to try to
improve robustness by taking advantage
of of extra cores and so the thing about
parallelism is that unlike sort of
taking away performance on a single core
where if I if I start running something
in the background and you only have one
processor you're going to notice the
effect of that probably but unless your
program is really taking advantage of
all the cores on the machine there's a
good chance that I can run something in
the background and you won't even notice
that it's running so that's one thing
that that changes things a bit so how do
we what can we do about to make things
more robust and to make them behave more
correctly so there are tools that both
are there both static offline tools and
online tools so the offline tools
like compilers they take your code they
look for problems and these these have
some nice benefits for example they can
they can prove things they can say it's
guaranteed that this will this property
will always be true but they also have
some limitations they have the standard
compiler limitations of not knowing what
really happens at runtime and having to
be conservative about that and sometimes
generating too many false positives
there are also tools that run
dynamically and so this you people know
you know all about these things here at
Microsoft but some common ones that are
used or things like Val grind or pin and
so on and these things run in the
background as your program is executing
and look for problems and in good cases
they can even hopefully fix some of
these problems the nice thing about this
is that it doesn't suffer from the
limitations of static and some of the
limitations of static of analysis of not
understanding what happens dynamically
you can see exactly what the program is
doing the only major downside however or
one of the major downsides is that
they're slow so the people who wrote Val
grind for example we're very proud in a
paper that they published several years
ago that their tool was running was only
slowing things down by a factor of 25 in
fact that is that is pretty good
compared to a lot of other tools but 25
is so bad that that means that you only
run this when you're doing debugging or
something special so just to put a
little more detail behind this there's
this is examples of two tools this is
one that's doing memory checking and
this is one that's doing security
checking implemented inside Val groin
and these are some benchmarks that I'll
say more about later and what you can
see is that this is address check is a
lighter way to taint check is a somewhat
more sophisticated tool and they're
slowing things down by a factor of safe
if teen to 35 for address check and here
it's 42 almost 65 for taint check so
what we'd like to do is so the problem
with this is that we call these dynamic
tools lifeguards that's our own
we just decided to call them so using
this the lifeguard analogy is a
lifeguard is watching over the kids that
are swimming in the pool looking for
problems and jumping in and saving them
if something goes wrong and the reality
is that software is swimming without a
lifeguard and it would be nice if we
could actually have lifeguards normally
that would make the world safer so our
goal is to have lifeguards not just one
of them but to have multiple of them all
the time and to have them running in a
way that it doesn't slow down your main
program you don't even notice that
they're there so you're happy to have
them running so that's that's the goal
how can we do that so the idea is that
at least the raw horsepower for doing
this will come from chip multiprocessing
so the idea is that let's say right now
I have a 16 processor chip it's running
my application on day four of the cores
right now and that means i have several
available cores and i can run my life
guards on them so that's where the raw
horsepower will come from but it's a lot
more involved than this because these
tools aren't just sitting there doing
their own thing on their own they're
actually they need to be intimately
connected with the program that they're
monitoring and that's where the problems
come from in particular the lifeguards
need to do two things the first is that
they need to monitor the behavior the
main program in fact many of them want
to monitor every instruction so that's
where a lot of the overhead comes from
is you have to go in and instrument the
each and every instruction and look for
all the state that's why things are so
slow and the second thing that you'd
like to have is to not only observe a
problem but to fix a problem and to do
that you have to have a way of rewinding
things patching things up and rolling
forward again and the the reason for the
name of this project is we got excited
about the idea that possibly a single
new hardware supported mechanism could
provide both of these things observation
and roll back and
would be a log so logging is a very old
idea in computer science it's been used
in databases and final systems and lots
of different contexts and the idea here
is to actually have the hardware be able
to capture a log as the program is
executing and export that log to a
lifeguard so here's a little cute
picture of how this would work so your
your program is running here on one
processor the lifeguard specifies what
it cares about it says okay I want to
look at every instruction I need to look
at the data addresses and the registers
the hardware then captures that log and
publishes it in a way such that this
lifeguard can run over here and consume
that information and the hope is that if
we do this the right way once you once
you can publish your log you can
actually attach multiple lifeguards to
this log without any observable without
any significant slowdown in the main
program so we're just affected Lee multi
casting the log out to lots of different
lifeguards so that's the goal so that's
the first part is lot that's how logging
can provide the runtime observability
the second thing we want from a log is
to be able to rewind and so that might
be used though there might be errors
that we can actually recover from so for
example if a bad packet comes in over
the network that has a virus in it we'd
like to be able to back up kick it out
undo it side effects and roll forward
again so as the programs running and the
lifeguard is watching it it may notice
that something bad has happened so then
using potentially the log you can do a
little rollback fix things up and then
roll forward again so the goal the
immediate research goal the main the
main question we're hoping to answer in
this project is whether these logs are
useful enough that it makes sense to add
the hardware support to processors
that's the question that Intel cares
about and in particular you know some of
the other questions are can we generate
useful logs without slowing down the
main
program in fact this is the easiest
question to answer I'm pretty confident
that we can do that the harder one is
the second question it turns out the
bottleneck is is actually consuming a
log it's basically drinking from the
firehose not generating the fire hose
that's the problem so this is where a
lot of our our work is focused on and
then the thing that we're excited about
is we don't just we don't simply want to
take today's tools and make them run
fast enough that you can run them all
the time even though that's a great goal
we'd like to go beyond that and actually
do new things with this capability so
what what sort of dynamic monitoring
could would this enable that doesn't
isn't even thinkable right now hopefully
it'll be you can use it for that too in
fact in fact we started off the whole
project thinking about transactions and
realize that transactions are just one
of the reasons why you want to backup
and and so this would definitely support
transactions to we think so we're
talking a lot with the transaction
people at Intel also so here's what I'll
be talking about and again this this
work is at a somewhat early stage here
we're just getting our first graduate
students online on the project here but
I'm going to talk a bit more about
lifeguards and the ones that we're going
to use in this initial study then I'll
show you some of our early results where
we're looking at the potential benefit
of having this log and then I'll talk
more about how will implement the log
and why this isn't a crazy thing to do
and then I'll give you a sketch of where
we're going with this next so talking
about lifeguards we found that as we sat
down and made up our list of lifeguards
which is on my next slide they're
generally doing a some combination of
three things they're detecting things
analyzing problems and recovering so a
little picture here we're showing is
when something goes wrong you know
you're executing a long and time time
going from left to right and something
bad happens but usually you don't notice
that right away you keep on executing
until something really bad happens like
your program crashes so then you're in
deep trouble so the first thing is just
detecting that there's a problem and
ideally we want to detect so you can
think of this as checking an assertion
or making sure that some invariant holds
ideally we'd like to be able to take
that as early as possible we don't
detect it when something terribly bad
has happened it's just more efficient
actually if you can roll back it doesn't
really matter so well first step would
be to detect it that is true so that's
that's part of the reason why we'd like
to do it earlier rather than later so
the next thing you'd like to do is if
you want to simply if you want to be
able to fix the problem and you want it
the next step is to diagnose what really
went wrong at this point we've noticed
that something catastrophic has happened
but we want to find the root cause of
the problem maybe this is the arrival of
a bad packet or something so that so
what we have to do now is sort of look
through the past and figure out haha
that's actually the thing that went
wrong and then if we're able to we like
to then back up fix things and then roll
forward again if we can so these are
three different things that we would
want to do with the support in our
initial in this initial study I'll talk
about later really just focused on the
detection part so these are examples of
things that people that you might do
with this kind of support on the Left we
have different correctness checks so you
could check for a bad memory behavior or
security problems or data races and
parallel programs and so on there are
also performance things that you can do
like transactions which for some reason
isn't on my list for level speculation
you can even do things possibly like
unsafe code optimization
where if you know that there's this
monitoring and rewind capability in the
background you could actually move you
know do things that are normally ok but
not are not always ok if there's this
it's another form of speculation where
this this lifeguard can then notice the
bad case and rewind for you that may or
may not be a good idea but there are a
lot of things you could potentially do
well we're focused on so our goal
initially was to find three very
different lifeguards and use them to do
some initial investigation and we
focused we're focusing on three things
the first one is a memory checker and
this is part of Val groin so this is
checking for accesses to uninitialized
or unallocated memory and other bad
memory things the next one is tank check
it's looking for the side effects of
incoming network packets to see if they
could do things like modify the
addresses of indirect jumps or those
types of things it's looking for
situations where worms might be
infecting your system and then the third
one is lock set this is looking for data
races in a specific style of programming
its monitoring the set of locks that you
hold whenever you access data just to
make sure that their use consistently
and these vary in terms of their
complexity so address check is the
simplest of these things it only really
needs that they all have even though
they're looking for different things at
a high level they have similar patterns
which is there are particular events
that are very interesting so for example
an address check anything related to
allocating or initializing memory is
very interesting like Malik or free and
it does a lot of of stop work when those
events occur but those events are
relatively infrequent for lock set its
acquiring and releasing locks 14 check
its system calls then the other thing
that it's doing is it's propagating a
lot of information so it creates shadow
state for all of your main program state
for address jackets it tracks an extra a
bit for every bite in memory tank check
has two bits for every bite and lock set
actually has a full 32
bits for every 4 byte word in memory yes
your system how could you possibly
accomplish this let's see well I'm not
sure that I understand a question
because you know your application has a
certain footprint and so we're going to
these these tools actually require data
as well but the data that they require
is a small fraction of you know like an
eight or ball in this case it's it's
pretty significant but you can do other
tricks to you don't have to necessarily
statically allocate all the data up
front you could do it dynamically and
scale so you can't keep it on for
one day so now I'm starting to go off
chip every time you or a large amount of
time when you do a memory access to see
is is it it backed unallocated or you're
gonna have to pull those bits long every
time you do a memory access is that
we're going to do it um well i'll show
you in the results actually the memory
side of this is actually not bad at all
in that it has the same locality
basically the this extra state generally
has a very similar locality as a main
program so for the same reason that the
main program has acceptable cache
performance we have acceptable cache
performance here and we're running on a
different course oh it actually has its
own cash in fact it does because it as a
smaller footprint it actually runs
faster than has a better CPI than than
the main program so it's anyway it's not
a there's not a free lunch here these
these tools actually consume resources
they are going to take up memory and
they're going to consume cycles but yeah
assuming that you have some available
memory in your system you'll see later
that it's not not so bad oh and i want
to remind people that right now it's
terrible I mean right now we're running
like 30 times 50 times slower to run one
of these things so yes they are
intrusive right now
so okay so we'll be using those three
lifeguards and I have a lot more detail
on how they really work that if you want
to hear about that not only slides
unfortunately so we're going to take
those three lifeguards and evaluate them
and and this is just a very initial
study this is not a kind of Pisco Pisco
quality you know fully gory detailed
architectural study here what we're
using is simox running linux on top of
that and we're using a fairly simple
machine model which is all it's a it's a
scalar core so every instruction takes
one cycle except for memory accesses so
we do model two levels of cache
hierarchy with 16 k and half meg caches
that are a few way set associative and
so on and what we're comparing is what
we have today is your program is running
with the lifeguard functionality wrapped
into it so Val grind takes your program
at those binary binary rewriting inserts
all the instrumentation and all that
runs on a single processor and we're
using simox to model that so that's what
we have today well in our framework the
idea is that your program is running on
top of a processor where the hardware is
actually capturing all the information
you need for the log so there shouldn't
be any significant slowdown here other
than sticking this into a buffer which
is non-trivial I mean it's not zero
overhead but it's it's small in
comparison with what we have over here
so on this side we have the lifeguard
functionality running on a different
processor and it's consuming the log and
and executing that and we wrote we took
these tools and we rewrote them for the
given this idea of driving them off of
the log so we have an API to do that and
we wrote all the code and compiled it
and everything so this is a fairly
accurate simulation of what happens over
here and in terms of performance this is
the bottleneck so in fact what we're
going to be comparing is we'll look at
the main program running all by itself
than the main program running with this
and then finally what the execution time
is here okay and these are the applique
the benchmarks that were using so these
first eight were taken in the tradition
of architecture studies we borrowed the
benchmarks from somebody else's paper so
there's a paper that Brad Calder did on
and we took all of his his applications
because these are applications that had
some known bugs in them and then for the
one that detects data races we had these
two programs that we were running these
multi-threaded programs okay so the
first thing we're going to look at is
just the instruction count so this is
not anything like real wall clock time
but let's see how running with based on
logging support alters that okay so for
each of these benchmarks there are four
cases on the left the one labeled n
that's with no lifeguard and that we
normalize that to one so that's the
amount of real instructions the number
of instructions in the original program
the next bar is running this is for
address check this is how many
instructions we have to execute for the
Val grind version of address check and
that's a much worse and we in the paper
this is broken down into something like
six different categories but I broke it
down and get into just to hear the red
part is the quote wheel work this is the
work that you really need to do to do
the checking of bad addresses and this
this teal color is all of the other
overhead of doing instrumentation this
includes things like the fact that you
have to spill a lot of registers because
all the registers were already allocated
there's a lot of other instrumentation
overhead in there okay so in the course
of writing our version of the code which
is over on the far right chemin found
many opportunities for improving upon
on the vowel grind code there were other
ways to improve it so in fact he went
back and put those back into the Val
grind version of the code also because
we wanted to be doing an
apples-to-apples comparison so this
third bar labeled 0 is optimized Val
grind so you can see that the amount of
real work has been reduced significantly
in many cases here because he's doing a
better job of what they were trying to
do and then finally on the right is the
logarithm lifeguard instruction count
and hear all of the blue part goes away
because the hardware is effectively
doing all that work for us it's
capturing all the information and just
presents it to the lifeguard code and so
it only does the sort of real work now
the way that we measure this real work
is a little bit of an art so the bars
don't line up perfectly here but roughly
speaking you know the amount of
instruction count is more or less equal
to the amount of real work in the
optimized Val gran case and we get to
delete all of that other overhead so
we've gone from something that's a 30 x
20 30 x times worse in terms of
instruction overhead to something that's
more like three to five times worse so
we still haven't reached our goal of no
overhead at all but but we've taken
we've knocked off a big chunk of the
overhead just with this hardware support
yeah
hardware on the log stuff but not
necessarily giving yourself a boost from
the valid right perspective just curious
if you envision what that might help how
much would it reduce the teal valgrind
had some support in hardware I guess we
didn't really have any guess we didn't
have any particular ideas about how to
accelerate bow grind other than doing
logging which we thought the right way
to do it so but yeah arguably this is
what we want without this is the
improved version of alkaline and our in
our view we didn't we didn't consider
any kind of in between electricial
program run the log base mission because
there's probably some will read for
publishing this stuff right right so in
this initial study we aren't we didn't
measure that but we were confident that
it was less than the so eventually it'll
it'll be slowed yeah oh I think it's
like ten percent it effectively all you
do is you stage the log entries in some
buffer and you stick them off into the
l2 cache periodically all of this is
stuff that can be hidden in the
background it's not none of it is
something that should cause the
processor to have to stall other than
eventually it stalls because the buffer
fills up and then and so for that reason
it's going to run slower but not not for
another reason so our goal is to
actually eventually i'll talk more about
how we want to reduce this overhead more
but that's right is this stuff sorry
that's right that's why we didn't even
bother to measure it because it this is
the purpose is the answer okay see you
to decide you just throw a lot of wine
right stop stop that's right if you're
willing to do sampling or something you
could you could run at the rate of the
whip you could run without slowing it
down and just throw away like you know
two thirds or four fifths of the log I
wouldn't actually work right you
preferred you prefer not that's right
you prefer not to do that so okay so
that was a break that was the previous
slide was focusing on just instruction
count and now what we're focusing on is
execution time with this simple model of
all that all the only thing that we lose
time on is cache misses and it's ten
cycles to the l2 cache and 200 cycles to
main memory now these are all with the
exception of mcf these are all fairly
small little tiny unrealistic programs
so they all tend to fit very well into
the l2 cache and they have some l1 cache
misses but this is the execution time
for the same four bars so it's again
normalized to the execution time of the
original program running just by itself
without anything else and so again we
see Val grind is significantly slower
and the interesting difference is that
if you were paying close attention the
height this is actually these are better
numbers than what we saw before so for
example mcf is running only 1% slower
than the main program and the reason for
this is that in mcf the main program
this is the only program that we have in
this collection that actually does any
real amount of have any real number of
cache misses in the main program and the
lifeguard has such a much smaller cash
footprint that it's running dramatically
faster even though it has three times as
many instructions it has so far fewer
cache misses that it actually catches
back up so we're actually running more
like say 32 no 1 2 3 to 4 X it's five in
this case slower which is a little
better than it was if you look just at
the instruction count and you can see
why on this slide this is
plotting the number of primary cache
misses per instruction for the main
program for the main program combined
with Val grind and for the lifeguard
alone when it's log driven you can see
that the lifeguard usually has fewer
mrs. than the original program and
especially in mcf that's why it manages
to run so fast in our model it's not we
give it its own core and that's a key
part of the reason why it can run faster
it is yes hey that's right they have a
physically shared l2 cache but different
separate l1 caches and type it is it is
competing for l2 cache bandwidth but but
it does fairly well out of the l1 cache
so it's the keep the problem is in the
middle case with Val grind they're
competing with each other it's mostly
the problem is remember that bottleneck
is the lifeguard the problem is that the
main program is stepping all over the
lifeguard it's not that the lifeguard
stepping on the main program so we
actually want to give the lifeguard its
own cash so that it can run faster
because it's the thing that we need to
accelerate
so that was the first of the three
lifeguards the second one is taint check
and taint check is is a more
sophisticated lifeguard it's tracking
the flow of whenever a packet comes in
from the network it tracks the flow of
data that's touched by that so address
check only had to really do work on
memory references for every load and
store we had to check to see if that was
okay here for every instruction that
propagates a result even register to
register instructions we have to take go
look up the state for the inputs for it
together and store that for the result
so that's why we have more work to do in
this case so we have the same four cases
this is instruction count the original
Val grind optimized vial grind and our
case and let's see the thing that may
look surprising here well the first
thing to point out is again we're doing
very well in terms of instruction count
we're down typically in the about four
or five range this case is closer to 10
and that's a little more than five in
terms of instruction count the thing
that may be surprising is why is our
amount of real work so much smaller than
the amount of real work even in the
optimized bal grind case this is
somewhat of an artifact of the way val
grind works but it's real which is val
brine takes x86 code and it turns it
into MIT into risk pseudo code and then
regenerates x86 code it turns out that
when it does that it introduces a lot of
temporary registers because it doesn't
like to do memory memory operations and
it has to track the flow of data through
all of those temporaries and that's the
thing that results in all this extra
real work that it has to do because of
that design decision in bao grind but
the other thing that's interesting is
that even though this is a much more
sophisticated and heavyweight tool we're
still only about roughly five x worse in
terms of instruction count and there's
sort of details in the paper about why
that why that's the case but that's but
that's a real number and
we again have the same benefit of the
lifeguard having a smaller footprint
than the main program and if you look at
execution time these numbers look even
better so again for mcf we're running
not even 2x slower and many of these
cases are less than 5x slower running
this this life guard so finally we
didn't get as far down the path of
evaluating this lifeguard but this is
the one that's doing data rates
detection and we have this is an even
more heavyweight case because it has to
track more state rather than having a
bit or two for every bite this one has
sort of one-to-one overhead because it
tracks the set of locks through a full
32-bit pointer for every bite for every
word in main memory so you can see
there's fairly large overhead here this
is execution time and we did increase
improve that by a factor of five to ten
but there's but the overhead is still
high less than 10 but higher than you
saw before because this is even a more
sophisticated lifeguard but it is an
order of magnitude better than valgrind
at least so to summarize this yep
between the four the log I'll get to
that in a minute so I have a whole
section on that so it's a good question
so from what we've seen so far without
any details about how we're going to
actually transport this log compared
with Val crying we're seeing fairly
impressive performance improvements like
roughly an order magnitude or so speed
up in terms of this relative to a very
bad slow down so we're going from say 30
times slower to 5 times lower or three
times lower so we're not completely
there yet but we've made a lot of
headway and later I'll talk about our
ideas for getting it down to the point
where there's no slowdown and the reason
why we're seeing so much benefit is it's
two for two reasons the first is we
avoid any
imitation overhead because hardware is
going to do this for us in particular
the thing we wanted to point out is it's
not just it's it's not just sort of
obvious instrumentation but there are a
lot of things that you want to track
that are readily available to the
hardware that are somewhat painful to
reconstruct and software things like
instruction addresses you know that's
something you actually have to propagate
along separately in in software if you
care about that even though the hardware
has it trivially in the pipeline so it's
it's fairly it's much easier for
hardware to pull out this information
the second reason why we're improving is
that is that we're giving the lifeguard
more resources we're not forcing it to
piggyback on the same processor as the
main program we're giving it its own
core and that's important not just in
terms of execution cycles but also for
registers it doesn't have to go in and
spill every register from the main
program and do lots of of spilling there
also it gets its own cash it gets its
own primary cash and that's very
important especially because since it
has a small flip cash footprint it can
run fairly efficiently that way so
that's what we've seen so far the next
thing I want to talk about is some
initial thoughts on a study of initial
study on how we would implement this so
one question that people often ladies is
what do you what is the log capturing
exactly and you know the the quick
answer is is as little as possible no we
don't the idea is not to have the log
always capture everything it could
capture all the time the idea is that
the lifeguard will explicitly register
this view and say I only care about this
information for these kinds of
instructions and that's all that will
capture if you have multiple lifeguards
then we'll take the union of what they
need and we'll capture those things but
typically what we're looking at is sort
of software visible architectural state
things like store memory references
register values that type of stuff
definitely things like system calls
and for the instructions you care about
which could be everything or just memory
references sometimes it's special events
like locks and memory allocation events
or system calls those are very important
things depending on the lifeguard you're
doing sometimes sampling might be okay
we're also interested in having things
like software generated annotations in
the log so it may be easier to
communicate some high-level semantic
concept by just sticking an annotation
the log then trying to reconstruct it
out of assembly code effectively and
there may be cases where you want
certain micro architectural events like
cache misses but generally we're not
worried about capturing these things so
if you think about performance counters
they're usually capturing lots of micro
architectural events that's not
particularly what we're interested in
here we're mostly focused on these
architectural state changes so one
example of what the law a particular log
entry might look like is is this it
could have the instruction address a
memory address the type number of
operations operands and a map of which
registers it used in fact that with that
sufficient for all the lifeguards that
we looked at yes so then so yes so
that's a lot of data so that's the first
concern is that's about 15 bytes and
that sounds scary so for every you know
real instruction I'm generating a lot of
data so this is why you know everyone
well you know we first talked about this
idea to anybody until they go you know
no no that's that's a crazy amount of
bandwidth so so what can we do about
this so the idea yep
compare exchange 8 bytes which is become
very important for us you're the heck a
lot more than that I would assume to
capture the necessary state about
blocking instructions basically it is
free of my missing inner you mean you
mean because boils down to LA compare
exchange descriptions okay track okay
right yes so they can be the record can
be longer than this if you've got a more
complex instruction that actually has
multiple memory references and then you
would be even bigger than this so this
would just be for instruction that does
one memory address one memory reference
so but it's still true that this is a
lot of data so and so what can we do
about this so the idea is well the first
step is do a lot of compression and the
way that this might look is that you
have hardware that's just kept that can
potentially get into the pipeline and
capture the state that you need and
you're only you're using filtering to
pull out only some of this information
so you might get some improvement by
just filtering things you don't need for
example address check doesn't need the
register map but I showed you on the
previous slide and it also doesn't need
the instructions that aren't memory
references but after you do filtering
you then want to do some compression
before you actually ship the log or
store it and then decompress on the
other side and the way that we decided
to do this compression is there's
actually been a lot of recent work on
using value prediction techniques to do
to compress instruction traces mostly in
software and the insight is that if you
take this if you go back and look at
this structure and if you break apart
the different pieces of it things like
the instruction trace it actually may be
very easy to predict that with a with a
good value predictor so for example
what's usually moving along sequentially
until you reach a branch and then it
typically goes to a well-defined place
so you can build a good predictor and
hardware that can predict the
instruction stream maybe you can build a
different predictor or
predictors that can predict memory
addresses and so on and then you have
these same predictors on both sides you
have actually I've got a picture on the
next slide so what you have is you have
a set of predictors that can predict
instruction addresses a set of
predictors that predict memory addresses
and what you do is you take advantage of
the fact that on the receiving side it
can Ricans it will reconstruct the exact
same state in its own predictor so all
you have to do is that if one of these
predictors is right you just tell it
which predictor to use and that's the
only thing you need to encode is the
predictor ID so you pass along predictor
IDs for these different pieces of the
stream yes make the vc's you can just
communicate the brash directions right
one big branch yes so yeah so that's
that's right side by able to look at the
original instruction original bites of
the program are you ruling that out
actually in this design in this first
design we weren't actually looking at
the binary so if you're if you're
willing to go look at the binary you can
do more now one thing that we are doing
though is there are parts of the record
that are static that don't that never
change for a given instruction like it's
register map so for those we would pass
them along the first time we encounter
them but then later as long as weary
predict accurately we didn't bother to
send it again so we assume that on the
consuming side you'd build up a table
that way so there it
yeah so this was just a way to think of
it this is just a summer interns first
crack at designing this so this is this
is I'm not defending this is the right
way to design it this is just a way to
do it so I think that there are you know
that's a good question that's a
perfectly valid alternative way of doing
this I mean you can imagine doing a
really really good job of predicting an
instruction screen just as the branch
predictors do now so you might be able
to do a lot better than what we're
showing here predicting the memory
addresses is more interesting that's
that's a little bit more difficult and
so the idea is that you as long as
you're predicting these things correctly
you just indicate the predictor when you
miss predict then you actually send
along the full information that you need
and then you keep going and then the
other thing that we do is we add a run
length encoder on top of this so that if
we have correct predictions a sequence
of the same correct predictions will
just say well use that same thing 10
more times so if you're in a loop or
something you can take advantage of that
so then the punch line is we start off
with something that's on the order of
say fifteen bytes per instruction the
first step is to do some amount of
filtering in the case of say address
check where you don't need the register
map that's that that reduces it a little
bit but then the trace compression this
this approach right here gives you about
an order of magnitude reduction in in
bandwidth so we go from about 10 to 12
bytes or 15 bites down to about 1 byte
per instruction and that's using 16
kilobytes worth of hardware for the
predictor tables and then if you use the
run-length encoding you get another
little boost from that and it gets it
down to about point 8 bytes per
instruction and then this is a typo this
is not for address check this is for
everything and this is address check so
just ignore that part of the title but
this is showing you the results for the
different benchmarks so it does vary
from benchmark to benchmark a bit
on the Left we have okay so we have as
bites for instruction and it's broken
down into two parts the bottom part is
the information that set since whenever
there's a misprediction and the top part
in light blue is when we predict
correctly so here we're just
communicating which predictor to use and
the run-length encoding on the right and
it's able to compress some of this
correctly predicted information it
doesn't do anything to compress in this
predictions so on average we're down at
around point eight bytes per instruction
if we add run-length encoding so the
point is that that number if you're
about at roughly a byte per instruction
that's comparable to the amount of l1 to
l2 traffic that we expect for say the
instruction stream and the data stream
so this would be you know a third stream
of comparable of a comparable magnitude
the good news about this is that if
you're using this just the way we are to
have a lifeguard monitor something in
real time that's running on the same
chip that bandwidth never goes off the
chip so this is entirely on chip
bandwidth so it seems reasonable to have
an on-chip interconnect that can handle
say fifty percent more traffic it we're
a little more concerned about having to
go off chip where a pin bandwidth is a
little more precious so this so even
though 15 bite sounded scary one bite
doesn't sound so scary this also means
that in terms of buffering this if we're
going to buffer this in the cache if
we're willing to devote say a megabyte
to this buffer that means we get a
million instructions that's a very big
window we don't necessarily even need
anything that big to do what we're doing
so we can even get away with a fairly
small chunk of the cash for this and
still do what we were doing there now
that's if we're just doing runtime
monitoring if we're just doing this
basically detection but if we want to do
analysis or recovering we need to move
further back in that case we'd like to
have a long history so how are we going
to deal with that we can't keep the log
forever
so what we envision is that in the
recent past you'll actually have a fully
detailed log so to the extent that you
can buffer it on ship easily you'll have
all the detail you'll need and you can
do anything you want to with that
however when you start running out of
space and you have to push it deeper
into the memory hierarchy you may have
to start doing throwing more things out
in fact you have to probably go beyond
lossless compression at this point what
we envision is that the lifeguard will
actually have to tell you how to do this
it could say well if you have to throw
things out please keep this around or
please you know just compute this
aggregate statistic because that's still
useful to me and so over time that
you'll have this tale where you'll have
less detailed information as you go
further back in the past that's that's
the thing where that's our current
thinking about this so one of the
reasons why I'm excited about this from
an architecture perspective is that in
in other contexts when people have added
logging you know that it's easy to start
off by thinking of the log is just
simply being this extraneous thing
that's on the side so you think okay I
have my memory image and that's the
truth and I'm going to access that with
my loads and stores and oh yeah I'm
going to store things in the log because
I have to do that but that's just
overhead but another view of the world
is actually if I'm going to bother to
generate the log maybe I could make more
use of the lock maybe I could go
primarily to the log to do loads and
stores and only go to main memory if I
don't find something in the log and this
has some advantages so for example if
you are doing rollback you can simply
keep a pointer to where you are within
this log and roll forward and backward
by just moving this pointer because it's
much more painful to do roll back and
we've all fallen backward in a
monolithic memory image
to work you mean how do you look at the
right right so the trick would be to
build hardware that would work like a
really big write buffer in some sense
we're like the right buffer you have to
go look in the buffer first to see if
it's there before you go look here so we
we have some ideas about how to do that
so this is it's just a lot bigger the
difference is that a write buffer you
tend to do a fully associative look up
on it based on the address and in some
sense that's the same idea here you but
you want it to be what's that yes you
have to find it here if you have this
model and you do a load you have to find
the most recent store in this buffer so
the question is can we find a hardware
structured that will locate it fast
enough that this is acceptable so all
right so that's what we're brainstorming
about the idea would be to build
effectively an index or some form of
fast hardware index that would let us
quickly take the ideas you would you
would actually have a way think of it as
a maybe like a bloom filter where you
would say here's a whole section of the
log and I can quickly tell you whether
it's definitely not in this section or
whether it may be is in that section and
if it may be is then I kind of iterate
down a little bit my question across
okay um this is a good idea where people
that are building my fellows are you
doing people every bus is marcus is
harder than a store buffer so this could
work and then you could apply all those
techniques to a write buffer and if it's
a good thing then why um it may be the
reason why okay well and sometimes
people are doing this today in that if
this was say you know 16 entries big
then yeah that's a write buffer and
they're doing that exactly today it's
just that right buffers are small enough
that you can argue you're going to buy
techniques for making big write books
yes it might be slower and then it's
going to start on the processor well
it's acceptable yeah so with the trick
is to find a way to not slow down the
processor you're saying is you're going
to design better write buffer send the
people who currently are designing my
coffers know how to do that's your
proposition they don't right now there
isn't a goal it's not there's no
advantage to making a right but for
larger because why is that managed for
you because we want to use it for rewind
I mean for rewind and for right with the
cash or ah that's my next one that's the
next slide so the next question is okay
I sort of lied a little bit there yeah
there is you can tolerate yes but but
this is this is all like yeah this is a
early early early research thinking here
basically don't have a knife doesn't
Jesus of memory barriers lemon eat size
is useful
uh yes yes because you know if you if
barriers occur frequently then you have
to flush the buffer when you reach it so
there's no point in making it very big
that's I don't know of any rule of thumb
number i think that could be very
variable i think an experienced
programmers tend to sprinkle them in
everywhere so you've end up with right
we're imagining yeah this this is be a
little bit yeah different from that
probably in it what we're imagining is
that unlike say you know you can also
look at this and say isn't this just a
reorder buffer because the reorder
buffer is also this buffer of
instructions that it's optimized for
rewinding and it's really just time
scale that's different you know they
built Hartley now to build hard swear
structures that make sense on a certain
of a certain size but we're thinking
about something that's much bigger so
we're imagining it's actually a
different solution because this isn't
first things like branch misprediction
million instructions possibly if so
other brings up yeah but this really
slams the door on the possibility of
having threads on separate chips because
you cannot access into his log in my log
at the same time to figure out if he's
just written to that piece of memory in
his log he's a million deep so this has
to be on ship you can't have any other
activity to those memory accesses
literally a completely isolated your
memories be completely isolated from the
other chip that's doing this and the
other chick that's doing this just when
or my missing something we've been at
restriction you can make a try to make
sure that I understand that is
restriction that you make
this is another form of a question that
I just asked about memory barriers yeah
but deeper this doesn't have to remember
ears this used to be memory well okay
whatever well I guess a million usually
we can get by usually memory there is a
lot more frequent than that right
actually there's a different answer to
marry it memory Barry thing but I'll
have probably take it offline if that's
okay I have to think about it for a
minute to date sir regarding whether
this is on a single chip yes the first
order it's it's hard to imagine doing
this if it's across multiple chips if
it's true that in you know a handful of
years we're going to have dozens or
hundreds of processors on a chip then
maybe it's still interesting even if
it's all on lunch if any boxes there are
several logs in winter but you're going
to query them off origami our processor
yes so this is like this is not even a a
half-baked idea so let me move on and
say this is something we're
brainstorming about the thanks these are
good good things wrong yeah that's great
the other the other question that arises
is that previous picture was not really
talking about caches I just said you
know memory and this was all one big
chunk of memory but we have cash
hierarchies too how does the log in the
cache hierarchy fit together are they
completely separate because if they're
completely separate that's unfortunate
because now we have a completely
separate storage and then we have to
make some tough trade-offs do we you
know do we cash the log do we think that
the log is something that's in a virtual
address and the cash simply caches it
like any other memory access that might
be a very bad idea or an okay idea do we
get rid of do we somehow combine the log
and the cash into some new kind of fast
memory structure that can be accessed
quickly both by physical bye-bye address
and by temporal ordering that's
something else that we're thinking about
anyway those are all sort of hardware
details for say Intel to work out and
maybe that it's fun to talk about so now
I'm going to talk about some of the
things that are high on our priority
lists sort of moving forward and we
definitely like feedback here of course
you'd like feedback on everything but so
one of our highest priorities is just is
to figure out how to make all this work
for parallel programs so the the studies
I showed you so far were primarily for
single-threaded programs that was just
our first cut at this but we want to
have logging and monitoring working for
parallel programs so now that creates
other complications so for example i
have my parallel programming program
running and each core generating a log
and with you know sequential consistency
we imagine that there's some
interleaving of these different accesses
so conceptually what you might prefer a
way you might prefer to think about this
is we have individual logs and we
somehow merge them in a serializable
order and then we look at that and that
that would be an intuitive way to think
about all you know what's going on
across this entire parallel program but
it turns out that that's a very well we
were actually we ran it on a single
processor it was a parallel program that
was time multiplexed on one thread so we
didn't really run in parallel yet are
you holding her right lots
that's right so you can that's right it
doesn't have to be running parallel for
lock set to get the right answer so but
there's the problem of performance so if
I have you know 32 processors and I'm
trying to merge this into one log and
send that all to one lifeguard Corps
it's already the bottleneck and that's
going to make the problem worse so what
we probably have to do is have something
that looks more like this where the
lifeguard is paralyzed and there's for
most of the time there is a lifeguard
Corps that's mostly watching its buddy
the main application core but we have to
worry about inter thread dependences and
because the lifeguard state also has to
track that in some cases it didn't
matter for Locke said very much for
example but in other cases we think it
will matter so and to make that even
harder so for example the flight data
recorder project that Wisconsin did a
good job of efficiently tracking these
things if you were willing to go back
after the fact and reconstruct them
offline but in our case we want to do it
online and we want to do it very fast so
this is a challenging problem so again
we need to start with have by having
some sort of consistency model for the
lifeguard and one thing that we you know
one thing that we're kicking around is
that we can possibly take advantage of
the fact that there is a delay between
when the lifeguards execute and when the
main program executes and we construct
whatever dependences occurred in real
execution over here we can present the
data to the lifeguards in that same
order possibly even if that involved
delaying things artificially so that
when you read some state associated with
the Maine State in the main program you
will lead it as though you were
synchronized you know you will read it
as though you were reading it that same
instant here as far as you're concerned
that might be difficult to pull off but
that's something we're actively thinking
about
the second really big goal is we want to
eliminate slow down we not we reduce the
slow down from 30 to say five or three
but we want it to be no more than one
because our goal is to deploy these
things on live machines that are running
all the time and there are two tricks in
our bag of tricks that we haven't used
so far one of them is basically compiler
optimization so right now you can think
of our lifeguards as looking a lot like
interpreters because we don't take
advantage of program structure in any
way we just say oh it's a memory
reference here's what I generically do
for every memory reference or here's
what I generically do for every add
instruction but if we start looking at
basic blocks and loops and so on we
might be able to do some redundancy
elimination to speed things up now we
start walking down a slope there of you
know in the extreme you end up creating
a lifeguard that's a full full-blown
program that looks like your main
program but it's very different so for
every ad and your real program you might
have an oar in your life guard program
because it's using a different kind of
state they're interesting challenges
they're one of the things that we're
concerned about is you know if our
original program was buggy how do we
avoid creating a buggy lifeguard so you
have to be careful about taking too much
advantage of the main program structure
if the program was booked the second
trick and our bag of tricks is to simply
paralyze the lifeguards so if we if we
ultimately can't eliminate enough work
to have one for one instruction / ahead
then we want to spread the work across
different cores and this would actually
be very easy to do for the memory
checking program because it's
embarrassingly parallel except for
memory allocation events so effectively
have barriers for those but in between
those you could run completely in
parallel it's much harder for things
like taint check because this looks more
like data flow and you're actually
propagating values along so there we're
thinking about things like speculative
execution and value prediction and other
things we think they're we're optimistic
that we can do things their mother
trying to be some sort of hybrid you're
logging scheme in your old rewriting
scheme where you would like to program a
little bit yes yes we would we would
that's that's what we imagined doing is
sort of trying to incrementally apply
these optimizations maybe if that's what
you're asking we weren't imagining
changing the original program we were
imagining changing the lifeguard code
and the way that we describe the
filtering so we would say when you reach
this basic block don't give me all that
logging information I only need you know
this and this because I understand the
structure of the whole block and I've
well that have to be something that we
programmed into the hardware so in the
filtering box you'd have to that's
that's an open question I don't know
yeah you could all that's one way to do
it but that's a possibilities we could
actually just directly annotate the
original program to to to do this as a
design choice I'd like to avoid that if
I can but we'll see I just don't want it
yeah you would have to do it for that
it's just religion so no good reason so
let's see let's see we also want to have
lifeguards that actually take advantage
of rewind we haven't looked at that yet
that's that's a big thing on our to-do
list and we're especially interested in
whether we're able to rewind past system
events because that would be useful of
course you can't want rewind past any
any old system event but we think that
there may be some events that we can
rewind past if we have the help of say
virtual machine monitor layer that's all
that would help us buffer some events so
it may be possible to say
yeah i'm going to do under certain cases
I've done this thing but I have a way of
logging or replaying this so that if I
rewind I could kind of undo it and then
go back forward again obviously if you
send a network packet out across the
internet there's not a way to kind of
undo that their side effects that you
can't undo launching the nuclear
missiles one people like to use for some
reason that's a let's see we spent a lot
of time in storming about that so I
don't have a short answer but we're
thinking about the idea of containers
that describe the effects that a
particular thread has had on other
threads within the program and then the
effects of you know a process on other
processes and so on so that when you
rewind a particular point you would have
a way of figuring out to what extent
this has had side effects on other
things and you have to go back and
rewind those things or make a decision
about whether you were going to do that
or not okay that's good to know okay oh
okay oh good I'd like to hold a okay
great if all that cop you sure that's
stuff is going to fall off your million
right so there's every step you cry in
order to track what was there before
you read modify write and actually store
the read the read data in your log so
that you can remind otherwise there's no
way where you want so now you're fifteen
bites just jumped as well by another
eight bytes the whole reaction previous
day was there permanently thanks in
internal already modified that this
particular pipe do those kinds of
optimizations understand but still is
going to expand your pure pipe
significantly to have that old data
mm-hmm we haven't really we've we
haven't really waited deeply into the
support for rewinding yet and we're
imagining that this actually involves
some type of checkpointing and that
having just an undue log isn't
necessarily what you want to do to win
back very far but that you might you
know jump back to checkpoint and roll
forward or do other other types of
things and in fact even for hardware
transaction support people are proposals
for doing this with what hardware
acceleration but we want to take
advantage of all those things okay now
there's also so I've been talking about
the hardware but actually a lot of this
is the interesting stuff actually
happens in the operating system too so
the operating system no hardware just
captures the raw data but then it's put
into the address space and then the
colonel does a lot to manage it and make
sure that the right processes are
looking at it and so on so we're
starting to we've been putting the
support into this into Linux to to just
make it aware of the fact that we have
lifeguards and that they're connected to
programs and and to schedule them
together and so on a big thing that we
haven't focused on much is protection
and security so a bad thing would be if
a bad guy get got hold of your log or
compromise one of your life guards
because now can look at lots of things
one thing we're interested in this may
be a good idea or a bad idea but what if
we could use the logging to help you
know the operating system itself is
something that can be hard to debug so
maybe if we can use that so to
understand what it's doing that would be
good but that also creates a lot of
protection security problems challenges
I guess where another thing that we're
doing is a one of the people involved in
the project is has a formal verification
background
we're thinking about how we can combine
sort of static formal verification
techniques with runtime information so
that you would be doing some of each in
order to verify the behavior of software
we think there's actually a lot that we
can potentially do there and then
ultimately we're interested in not just
as i said earlier not just porting
existing tools but creating new things
that we that aren't really practical
today with his capability and another
thing that we're interested in is what
if what if the application writer not
just the lifeguard writer but the
application writer knew that there was
the support would they do anything
differently so would you good yeah you
could unsafe code optimization is just
one example so to wrap things up we
think that this hardware supported
logging mechanism may be the thing that
maybe this key thing that we need in
order to run these tools in real time
all the time on chip multiprocessors and
that that would be a good thing we've
seen our initial cut at this is reducing
the slow down significantly the
instruction overhead has gone down to
something like a factor of 5 X and when
we take into account the better cash
footprint of these things it's down to
say two or three X in many cases slow
down and our goal is to get it down to
no more than one x and then the
compression study we've done so far
suggests that the storage and bandwidth
related to the associated with this is
only about a bite or so per instruction
which seems feasible on chip and so you
know the ultimate goal is to make
software more robust and make it easier
to write parallel software so that's all
I got thanks
obligatory marketing thing there
well we imagine the log being managed
well in terms of the log is stored in
memory we imagine that the log like like
other resources that you manage on a
context which you would have some you
know the colonel would just say okay
they've got different process IDs or
whatever associated with them and I
simply point to a different space in the
address space and start filling a
different log I don't necessarily have
to throw the log away so I can preserve
the log across the context which if I do
it in memory the thing that's actually
hard for context switching and what I
talked about today was the predictor
tables for compression we've been we've
been struggling with how to make those
things work across context which is yes
more than obviously that's an assumption
yeah the only thing that we know of it
doesn't really work very well was the
part about the way we were doing
compression the the consuming thread
would have you'd have to preserve the
hardware tables across a context switch
and that's not fun so we're we're
thinking about how to get around that
problem but that's that's the major
glitch that we have
parallel programming especially to the
early unpersuasive reputed oh you know
how to write single trittico there's
going to be a hell of a lot of context
switching as they get their
synchronization well moving from poor
daddy's pride
and
thanks